Hello world.
It's the Raj and how are you supposed
to write a great research paper?
I've written and read my fair share of
research papers and I'm going to outline
the steps you can take to write one,
whether you're a phd candidate at
MIT or a freshman in high school,
maybe you're working on a blockchain
project and once you have an initial coin
offering or you found that the model
you built in care os and left training,
overnights managed to beat the state of
the art because of a simple tweak you
made to some hyper parameters,
whatever it is,
you should publish your findings.
So before you start your journey,
you got to remind
yourself to stay positive.
Research can be hard,
it can take long hours,
required tons of time studying
and experimenting with
no good results. In fact,
you might find that you were asking the
wrong questions all along and you need
to start from scratch and that's okay to
become world class in anything you do.
It's going to take more
than just knowledge like an
Olympic athletes aiming for
the gold medal.
You've got to have a positive attitude.
And the belief that you have the
ability to discover something awesome.
That's the real start to
writing a compelling paper.
Then you've got to come up with a topic.
Start by coming up with some questions
you have about the field that you're
studying. They can be broad, they can
be specific, they can be embarrassing,
whatever.
Just come up with a list of questions
that you personally want to know the
answers to and then try to find the answer
to those questions for yourself to a
level that you feel comfortable with
and would enable you to teach others.
Talk to some people and see what they
think to verify that you do indeed
understand the answer to your questions.
That could mean posting your understanding
to a subreddit or to stack overflow
or a slack channel. As a result of
searching for an answer to your questions,
you'll either find an answer in the form
of existing work or you won't find an
answer, which means you found a
good area for further research. Now,
what are the related
subtopics to this question?
Start narrowing down the
broader the question.
The harder it will be to
answer. It's much, much,
much harder to solve a question like what
is consciousness over a question like
what is a more optimal
strategy to generate suitable
distributions for a Monte
Carlo tree search? In the
words of Kendrick, you got
to sit down and be humble.
A well articulated paper that's laser
focused on a solution to a niche problem
is much more useful to the community
than an ambiguous solution to a broad
problem. The next step is to
collect your data. On this topic.
You're going to get a lot of
articles, blog post tutorials, videos,
and PDFs.
When you Google it,
you'll need to go through each of
these systematically, but remember,
not all sources are created equal.
Just as it's important to be able to
search through a wide variety of sources.
It's also just as important to learn
to be critical in your assessment.
A source could have a possible
political or monetary bias,
so pay attention to who wrote it, their
qualifications, why they wrote it,
and when it was produced.
To see how up to date it is.
Pay attention to the domain,
extension.edu and dot Gov's can be
more reliable sources than dotcoms,
which could be pushing
content that persuades you to
purchase something. Ideally,
you find empirical research
that is knowledge gained
through direct or indirect
observation of experience. Popular
journals, conference submissions,
even social media like sub reddits and
Facebook groups have people sharing
relevant research daily. Google scholar
is another good way to find papers.
Just make sure to be specific in your
keywords so they relate to your topic.
If you find the paper you
really like that seems relevant,
go ahead and jot down some of
the cited sources it lists.
You can find those later and use
those as well for your own research.
Now you're ready to feel the learn.
Find yourself a cozy spot that you feel
comfortable in and start learning from
your sources. Try to make
generalizations. You are the synthesizer.
You are taking different
ideas from different sources
and putting them together
in a way that no one has thought
of before. For whatever reason,
you'll find common ideas
across different projects.
Some will have more
successful implementations
of those ideas than others.
This can take anywhere from a
single day to several weeks.
After this synthesis of data,
you'll come to some kind of belief,
some kind of possible solution that
you think might work for your problem.
Use this as your thesis.
This is a declaration of your
belief based on the data.
Your paper will be you defending that
belief through a series of compelling
arguments based on your own results
as well as the results of others,
and don't worry too much
about having it be finalized.
Your thesis will naturally change as
you experiment and develop your ideas.
Ask for validation of your thesis
from people well versed in your topic.
You don't want to spend your valuable
time researching something if it's not a
good idea. Email, paper,
authors directly or ask your question
on relevant social media platforms.
Once your thesis is validated,
go ahead and try to solve the problem.
It's really easy to get bogged down in
one implementation detail or carefully
tuning the wrong algorithm.
To avoid this.
Your first goal should be
to get something super,
super basic in place as quickly as
possible. That solves the problem.
Then once got a functional baseline,
you can get creative.
I actually learned this technique
from the Google glass team. Peace.
Once you feel comfortable
with your solution,
it's time to start writing an outline.
Look at papers related to your thesis
and see what kind of subsections they've
listed.
A lot of times you'll find some common
sub section headings between different
papers.
Go ahead and create a list of subsections
that are a generalized form of the
related papers.
Then think about if there are any extra
subsections you might want to add that
are specific to your project or even
some that you might want to take away.
Generally the format for an
outline should start with a title,
then an abstract which
will summarize your work.
Then an introduction that will give
the reader some of your motivations and
background data,
the methodology.
We'll document your research process.
Then your results,
a discussion at the end,
weighing all the different results,
a conclusion that uses the results to
answer your thesis and finally references
which will cite your sources.
Once you've done all of that,
you're ready to write your first draft.
Welcome to the world of technical writing.
This is the art of writing about
a technical topic in an engaging,
informative,
and educating way.
You are being of service to the larger
scientific community by writing this
paper, so don't try to sound smart
for the sake of sounding smart.
Rather get your point across in
the most efficient way possible.
Using language that ideally
your reader already understands.
Go into excruciating detail explaining
every single bit of your work,
every reference,
everything.
It's much easier to cut down a long paper
than to continually try to add more to
it to make it seem longer.
The ideal length for a paper is between
five to 10 pages and he less and you
aren't being detailed enough and any more,
and it's going to be a bit too long to
maintain the interest of the reader.
Support every statement you make
with evidence and never, never,
never played your eyes.
The whole point of this paper is to
show the synthesis of the ideas you've
learned about in your own words, and
it's always better to show than to tell.
Use tools like omnigraffle and
Inkscape to create graphs, charts,
and conceptual diagrams to help
illustrate your line of thinking.
The flow of your paper should have all
of the subsections appear interconnected
rather than starting and stopping in
a blunt way from one topic to the next
smoothly segue into the next topic.
Don't be too harsh on yourself.
The first draft. Just get something,
anything down, just let it out.
You can iterate on it later.
If you spend too much time trying
to make it perfect on the first go,
you'll never get anything out, so just
crank it out and iterate. Remember,
only you are reviewing this thing at
first. Once you've got your first draft,
congratulations, you are
awesome. Time to revise. First,
go through your paper and
check for content errors,
anything having to do with grammar,
misspelled words, et cetera.
Then check for factual errors
or your number's correct.
Double and triple check them.
You might find once you've written a
first draft that rearranging your ideas
would be more beneficial to
having a compelling argument.
That one idea is actually
a dependency of another,
so it's better to place it afterwards.
In fact,
entire subsections could be rearranged
to make the paper flow better.
Eventually after some mixing
and matching and revising,
you'll have a final draft.
You can then add some optional
content if you'd like,
like a table of contents at the
beginning or an appendix at the end.
Once you've done all of this,
you can submit your paper to a popular
journal like nature or a popular
subreddit for your scientific
community or even just get hub.
The point of this is to get your
research in front of as many eyeballs as
possible and get them
to learn from your work.
It's kind of hard to get a paper accepted
in some of the top journals as the
peer review process can be very, very
thorough. Basically, the journal,
we'll ask a few other scientists,
well versed in your topic
to validate your claims,
to ensure the integrity
and soundness of your work,
but if they accept it,
getting published in one of these
journals is an extra credential for your
paper. It gives it more technical
authority amongst the community.
Are you ready to become
the next Alan Turing?
Yet it's inscribed to continue to level
up your learning game. And for now,
I've got to hone my craft,
so thanks for watching.